hi i'm dan radcliffe and today i'm going
undercover on the internet to find out
what you've all been saying about me
it's actually me
[Music]
seriously it's actually me read it
whoa my friend that does toilet seat
portraits painted daniel ragland last
night let me have a toilet seat god i've
never looked better
is it wrong with me to want to start
getting this all over twitter so we can
see if he'll see it and respond whoa
somebody with an intense username
bombing of dresden
i mean that is but anyway it's much
nicer than i actually look in real life
if only i looked as good as i i do on
this toilet seat
thank you to you and your friend today i
learned that for six months daniel
radcliffe wore the same clothes every
time he went out in public
so that the paparazzi could not sell any
photos of him and somebody else has
asked can
someone else explain to me why these
photos would be unpublishable i've heard
this fact before but don't understand it
is it because every photo he looks the
same why would that preclude publishing
or selling them
so yes that that is why it is in fact
because in every photo he looks the same
no thumbs thank you for your question i
have also since been given
something which is way better than uh
that there is a jacket that you can buy
which is reflective which has a hood so
that if somebody takes a flash
photograph of you all they see when they
look at that photo is a floating glowing
hoodie
and nothing else so it worked and they
were really annoyed which gave me
some sick satisfaction daniel radcliffe
just posted this moments ago
could they be filming the cursed child
no i did not post that moments ago
this seems to be a photo of me from
filming the
the epilogue on film seven i do not have
a
public instagram i did not post that and
if you are
talking to somebody who is telling you
that they are me
uh they are not and give them all kinds
of [ __ ] for pretending to be
me youtube is actually me
leonardo ramos asked what a beautiful
dance what is it
the naynays although i love the
britney's part
yeah um so this is a video of me and my
wonderful long-suffering girlfriend
during swiss army man we all went out
and did karaoke
and at the end of the night i got up and
did my rendition of uh the real slim
shady
um which i knew all the words to when i
was nine and so really has stayed in
there
and i was like quite reticent about
getting up and doing it because the
chorus is
really long there is a lot of just
saying won't the real slim shady please
stand up so
my girlfriend was just like i'll just
get up and like be your hype man and
just like shout stuff during the chorus
and do the chorus for you and thank you
this person who filmed it and put it on
youtube if you really wanted to kill me
you've already done it how tf did he do
that american accent
thank you blackham7 i honestly think
that british actors
on the whole we're so exposed to
american accents when we're young like
so much the tv we watch is from america
i would play with my wwf as it was then
action figures i would give them
american accents so i think i've kind of
been practicing my american accent since
i was about six
i read it who would win in a race in
water between david hasselhoff spongebob
movie and daniel radcliffe swiss army
man
battle round one a race in olympic-sized
pool round two
same pool without david carrying
spongebob or patrick and daniel not
carrying paul dano
three raced from pier 39 to alcatraz i
don't know enough about the
details of that course final pier 39 to
address without okay
i mean i don't quite know what i'm
competing against in terms of david
hasselhoff in the sponsor movie i'm not
sure
what he does if he's just using his
super like baywatch powers to swim very
well
if that is it then i would say that i
would beat him
i don't know that i would beat him
without
paul dano though because i think my
character is a swiss army man is somehow
responding to paul dano being there so i
think without paul dano i think i might
just like
lie lifeless and limp but with him i
feel like i'm beating the half
submit it cora what if you were trapped
in an elevator with daniel radcliffe
well
i'm always trapped in an elevator with
daniel radcliffe it's fine it's quiet in
there what is the most badass thing
about daniel ragland
i have to say badass is just one of
those words that it is almost impossible
to say in an english accent because i
would say badass
like i would pronounce it like ass but
it's ass but if i say badass
it just sounds like i'm midway through
switching to american
so the least badass thing about me is my
inability to say that word
is it normal or special to be able to
twist your tongue in a way with three
curves
similar to how daniel radcliffe can do
it three curves is actually not
the hardest is the two you have to do it
says the one and then
two i don't know if it's normal
i think it's probably like the recessive
gene thing if you can like
you can do that or you can't i think if
you can roll your tongue you
are very highly likely to be able to do
the three you just have to like
concentrate and if you like keep
thinking of moving the walls of your
tongue together then eventually it will
just go into the three things
but let's just say we're incredibly
special next twitter
how am i supposed to ask daniel
radcliffe on a date if he doesn't have
any social media
you are much better off not dating me
and the whole world can can thank my
girlfriend for taking that hit for the
lot of you
yeah okay thank you selena post it
even more cora what is daniel
radcliffe's workout regimen
oh how are you all gonna wish you hadn't
asked i know that anybody watching this
is gonna find this hilarious because i
do not look like somebody who works out
at all i'm like the
classic almost cliched example of
somebody who gave something up within my
face drinking and then just like became
obsessed with working out i'll do like
one very long run well long for me like
eight to ten miles a week and then
various sort of circuit training and i
will do some weights i don't like to
talk about it because i am such a cliche
in that regard but it is true cora would
daniel radcliffe have made a good
spider-man
yes i would have made a very good
spider-man not in the films
i just mean in real life where i granted
those powers post it
imdb besides dan i know what a boring
nickname
no i don't have any other nicknames you
know on imdb it'll say like
trademark it said next to me my
trademark was short stature
i'm like i have not trademarked this i
you do not owe me money if you're also
five foot five yeah god i win now i
really wish i had a more interesting
thing anything damn
thank you very much to you the internet
for all of your questions
you you all stay relaxed and kind to
each other out there